oh yeah we're back it's been a month has
it been a month it's been a long time
it's been a minute good to see everybody
what's going on syn rise you Madeline
Sims in the house morones 1987 mop co-op
Series poles welcome everyone happy III
III II it's I'm gonna get this is how do
you do the e3 is there any three sign am
I doing this right
what's up this is the Moose welcome
everyone today we're gonna be playing
first let's give it up for our intern
Emma in the house
it is Emma right okay I don't know
people are learning their names I don't
know who I am today we're gonna be
playing a very fun game it's about
identity it's about what it means to be
human what it means to be an intern
versus a person who works on a show
we're gonna be playing Detroit become
human that's right that's right Andy
mutts we're back we're back Barney
what's up waffle tarts clap clap clap
for Emma no clubs
hey cream oh hey hey Zed Laughlin whoo
that's a great name I do love a
solipsism I'd rather have a bottle in
front of me than a frontal lobotomy
isn't that what they say okay well
anyway this game is amazing it stars
Jesse Williams Minka Kelly you got your
Lance Hendrickson you got a bunch of
famous people in this in what's
happening here in the thing I'd love to
launch the chapter all the claps for
Emma no fair no fair all right so this
game is great you could see every pore
on every person or androids face ooh
Oliver bottom in the YouTube chat just
made a comment I want to call it out
because it's my favorite comment I've
seen so far in the stream it just said
poo and it said poo with about 50 o's
poo it's great one clap for Erin and I'm
you know what
hey chronojet chrono Drifter what's up I
gotta say you know get give me I deserve
more than one clap I think I'm the guy
who pushed it to bring stream Coco back
today so Zen bow 7 ask Erin what your
favorite games from e3 I'm gonna say
if you haven't seen this cyberpunk 2077
trailer what are you doing with your
life
it's amazing first of all CD Projekt RED
so great
those guys are unreal and just the fact
that they hid some stream keys in our
some free Witcher games in their trailer
unreal those guys are great the fashion
looks great I'm interested to see what
they come up with so mom this is pretty
good should Kona play fortnight nits and
Nathan Martin Martinez asked no
absolutely not
he's terrible at shooting and he's
terrible at building and he's terrible
of video games and that's all for
tonight is it's a video game where you
build and shoot so here we go
I do think here's one of the other
things I'm from Michigan and I just
outside Detroit and I love the fact that
Detroit is like people in this game live
in Detroit it looks cool you know I'm
into that so here just to bring you guys
up to date on the story if you've never
played Detroit become human it's kind of
like a very glorified
choose-your-own-adventure so the idea
here is you play three separate Androids
they're three interlocking stories one
this is Marcus now Marcus used to be the
servant of a very famous painter played
by Lance Henriksen and and your
relationship with with your with with
the artist was very much he wanted you
to become human
he was very Pro Android rights he had
you read Plato
kind of that stuff and his drug-addicted
son he dies his drug-addicted son by the
way I'm gonna spoil a lot of stuff in
this game I should have just said that
right up top his drug-addicted son
blames you for his death you get taken
away and thrown in the trash and now
we've come back to life then you've got
a girl named Cara who is taking care of
a young girl because her dad was a
drug-addicted
a hole and I mistakenly shot him which
you're not supposed to do and so car
I'm on the run with this little girl and
the third the third story is this
detective named Connor and he is a new
Android he's a new prototype model he's
working with a human detective played by
Clancy Brown who's amazing if you see a
Highlander he plays the keurig on who
the bad guy that movie Clancy Brown is
unreal and very great actor and it's
funny because all these stories kind of
interlock so like Connor at one point
you played Cara who's trying to outwit
Connor and then you play Connor and
you're trying to find Cara so you know
whatever majid boo says those keys were
not just the game - they were The
Witcher 3 goty edition so they got all
the DLCs with it as well which is so
amazing I agree
pretty great also guys great huge
announcement I'm very excited about on
Monday we taped our very first mobile
clueless gamer that's right and we taped
it with one of my favorite people of all
time I'm just gonna show you a photo
here can we go fullscreen on me by the
way I'm gonna show you a photo of close
gamer this airs on Thursday it's our
very first mobile clueless gamer in
conjunction with Google Play and here it
is hold on wait for it oh this is gonna
be great when I can't find it
oh cool cool all right cool can't find
it this is great this is going very well
ah here we go one of my favorite people
of all time there's a photo right here
oh you know I'm gonna turn the phone
sideways so you can see it better here
we go here we go is it gonna work that
was the question yeah well look at this
get ready get ready we're all very
excited Ron Funches everybody that's
right
good old Ron Funches and there's me I
think in this photo I'm just farting a
lot I think I'm just it's just a massive
fart but there you go so yeah it's very
very cool I'll show you one other photo
from our shoot and this one I don't know
what I'm doing with my hands in this one
I hate looking at myself by the way it's
just a mess but here I'm not sure what
I'm what is this what am I doing here
what is this what is that pose I'm doing
what is this what are we doing here
I'm like this is what it's like to grab
a big ball of yarn is that that's the
pose I'm doing as I wanted this anyway
so ron funches very first mobile coolest
gamer and thursday very excited and ron
is one of those people where you can
just he just says something and it's
hilarious you know he's like look you
shirt and he's just like it's the
funniest thing you've ever I've ever
seen
this game is fun for a lot of reasons it
does a great job in world building which
I love you can go back to the game a
great job with world building and part
of that is you find these different like
iPad magazines around and it's really
cool you know I gotta say something I
play on the ps4 no one uses the touchpad
very few people ever use the touchpad as
a touchpad and in this game you do some
swiping left and right and that's kind
of a really cool thing it also has a lot
of uses a lot of motion controls which
is really cool
and makes things very harrowing when you
try to fight because you have no idea
what you're doing okay so I'm looking
for basically I'm looking for thing here
it's like I'm holding a large pug that's
trying hard to lick my face but I don't
have to like my makeup that's exactly
true that's what's going through my mind
what's my favorite androids has
following the Alpha ah favorite Android
oh this is it right here
my favorite Android in this game I
really love Marcus I think it's the one
I like the most because it feels to me
like the one with the most promise it
feels like I could go either way
where's kind of like Connor is kind of
like a goody-goody company man and Cara
is great but it's really depressing the
kharab storyline I've just totally effed
up man I've completely effed it up and
so every time I play that one I'm like
oh like I'm sleeping in an abandoned car
it's just it's it sucks for me it sucks
would you mind moving that
thanks man Zen bo7 wish you guys
streamed all the e3 conferences and did
a live reaction that's a great idea man
maybe we'll do that next year I love
that color commentary on the e3
hey three stuff rub my nipples I'm Rick
James I have very sensitive nipples so
I'd rather not that's okay with you but
I did call out your comments so I feel
like that counts for something
scheme looks amazing it's been hyped a
lot but I'm terrible at video games I
just watch you play and said I played it
battle ensues but this game is great for
people who are terrible at video games
because see she's inert by the way I
love little things - sorry this game is
great for people don't play video games
because it's a very easy game it's it's
the controls are not that difficult I
love little things in this game in terms
of like world building that I was
talking about Android temporary parking
it just goes that's a very subtle thing
that just shows like look how they're
not real people and look how they're
treated in this in this society where
it's like they have to stand in a in a
specific place they can't just see look
at the human just standing here
but the androids have to stand in the
Android parking little things like that
I really love about this game and make
me really appreciate the fact that the
team that wrote this game and came up
with it thought about those details of
how it might actually be if robots were
being used in society I also love look
at the graphics is a more awesome look
at the concrete here - what concrete is
amazing hey Tina's flowers what's up
it's been a long time I'm finding more
graffiti where's the Bronco bar
everybody's favorite
rising seven Android standing in the
back of the bus is like dropping a
metaphor Hana on us lol I do agree
however I think there are people who
play video games who could use a little
bit of a heavy-handed metaphor and if
you think the metaphor is heavy-handed
then you should be happy that you think
it's heavy-handed and that you can
recognize that versus oh hey that's
interesting it's just like civil rights
Jai Rajput man Conan do make fun of me
that's true and he beats me so I like to
stay out of arm's length oh I see it
online can't scrub these types of games
story they have tons of gameplay that's
true it really is more of a story but
again that's kind of one of the things I
really love about video games where they
are right now is as a medium as a
storytelling medium there's the next one
as a storytelling medium I find video
games very powerful because it's not a
reactive you know if you watch a movie
or watch a TV show or something that's
great too and there's a lot of obviously
great movies and TV shows or a book or
something and those can be very
emotional but a game the way it tells a
story you are in it and so what
something happens to the main character
happens to you and that's much more of a
visceral reaction which is awesome which
lets you know let's games potentially
tell much more powerful impacting
stories than reactive forms of
entertainment like TV or movies so and a
game like this I love the fact you can
have a game like halo which is amazing
and when the flood first appears in halo
that's to me as great a movie moment as
aliens when they're like game over man
you know inside the compound for those
of you born in 96 aliens is a very old
movie by James Cameron starring a
Sigourney Weaver and Michael Biehn you
should watch it it's great Bill Paxton
give it up but but yeah so that's an
amazing thing but then you also have
games like this which are very much more
just telling a story it's much more like
watching a movie rather than a game
where you're fighting a lot
it's deep man dizzi death we're going
deep dude that's what that's what it is
I also by the way speaking of e3 been
going not deep and not storytelling I
heard the new Smash Brothers trailer
trailer is unreal I don't got nothing
I need it says damn I should've got my
mom in here when you said that you
explained videogames perfectly well need
it you could take that to your mother
take it to your mother where do your
mother that's what I'm thinking of but
it's true and you know I got a say and
that's that's what's so cool right now
about being a video being gamer that's
what I love right now about the world of
games is I kind of feel like games right
now or where movies were in the 30s like
they're just starting to come into their
to their own into their potential I mean
the Last of Us I'm not gonna lie I cried
at the end that was awesome and no I
haven't seen the last of us to trailer
they have my money I don't want to spoil
it don't tell me anything I don't want
anything about Ellie I have seen shots
where she looks more grown-up and it's
awesome all right let's see what our
next thing is chain-link fence over a
robot they say they included everyone
but where's why Luigi and smash I don't
know haven't seen the trailer yet by the
way this sign I've seen in Detroit a lot
so these guys did their homework oh
we're looking for a chain-link fence oh
here we go there we got been and again I
don't mind games that are games don't
have to be super difficult and hard for
me to enjoy them like it's okay if this
game is little simplistic and it's uh it
doesn't all need to be you know the
witness where you're figuring out
insanely hard puzzles
well games now are also so easy nothing
really challenging l chamber Dark Souls
blood-borne what are you talking about
super meatboy by the way those games are
really hard I think games are very
challenging
lots of spoilers I have for you uh milk
a ba I would rather not you don't spoil
things for me but you know if you feel
like ruining someone's day to make
yourself feel better than by all means
what are some of the things coming out
of e3 that you guys are liking the most
by the way did anybody see the fortnight
50.50 tournament last night I saw some
Instagram stories from some of my pals
who are playing in that ron funches
played in that by the way I can do a
live III reaction right now it's saved a
trip to come you know for later
Zenvo 7 we don't have it loaded up
though we don't have the e3 stream but
you know what maybe that's something I
will do later this week it won't be but
or maybe I'll do it on my own account
that'll Fred's probably the easiest way
all right
I'm basically just looking for hashtags
I think is what this is see one there
you fortnight
damn oh man
I do love I gotta say not to not to crap
on YouTube but I look over every time I
look over the YouTube chat so we just
wrote poo poo pee pee nipples I mean
come on guys
hey I love you too Chris Shelley but you
know what for every poo poo pee pee
nipples there's and I love you so I
guess see that's what keeps me coming
back y'all that one-in-a-million I love
you a shock asked when I consider a team
of the Andy for clueless gamer we've
done a clueless gamer with Andy we did
when Conan and I and Andy plating up the
cast of Silicon Valley we played halo
get silicone valley which is great uh
yeah I'd love to have Andy for clues
gamer and he's one of the funniest
people I've ever met also in just
conversation
Andy is literally Andy is like one of
the funniest people I've ever had the
fortune of talking to he's just so quick
like you know and he obviously you know
came up through the improv a second city
I believe Chicago and he was responsible
I believe to for getting a lot of the he
was the link to a lot of the writers in
the beginning in the beginning of Late
Night with Conan O'Brien I want a close
gamer with you again yeah I mean again
you know a lot of people ask me I get a
lot of comments about can we get just
clueless gamers with you and Conan and
where will that ever happen again
I think it will but you know I think
that the gamers of celebrities are also
a flavor that people like to see and so
yeah I think I would I here's how I
would love to have it I would love to
have it the more complicated games like
Red Dead Redemption The Last of Us
Skyrim these games just Conan and I play
because then we can find comedy through
exploration and kind of digging kind of
like we used to through in the old game
gamers and then kind of simpler games
they're a little bit easier you know
like arms we did with wall Arnett you
know that kind of stuff
games that are a bit easier to play and
pick up I
think are fun are great for celebrities
you know like I gotta say like or if the
if the celebrity is a gamer like you
know the Final Fantasy with Elijah Wood
when him and Conan opened the door and
all the developers are out the hall that
was a great moment like Bill Hader
making you know making jokes with God of
War that was great you know and again
like the cast of Silicon Valley and meet
Cohn and Andy playing that was fun those
are fun moments so I think I think I
would like to see more I don't think the
celebrity gamers are ever gonna go away
I'd like to see more of a balance and I
think there will be a balance though sin
rise you yeah I agree with celebrities
both Conan it's just another version of
an interview with the background but we
it's gaming first yeah that's true I
think you're right can I jump this um
but yeah I mean like I said I you know
Conan is the boss and he gets to decide
what we do so and he right now wants to
do gamers with celebrities so I serve at
the pleasure of my president but you
know I do I do take my charge as a
advocate for gaming very seriously I
always fight to get more gameplay in and
I'll continue to do that and and I think
you know I think it's one of those
things where like I said I'd like to see
a balance and I think we will get back
to that balance so which is exciting so
but yeah I I agree i I I think it's for
me personally I I do enjoy when the
comedy comes from the game more than the
celebrity I think that's much more fun
and that's what makes a clueless gamer
unique Andrew Navarro do more close
gamers we've got our very first mobile
clueless gamer coming at you Thursday
with Ron Funches and me I'm also in it
and it's very exciting and I can't tell
you what the game is
but it's great and we I think we did
some really fun stuff I think you guys
are gonna be really excited
yeah very first mobile clothes camera
now let me tell you I almost had a
nervous breakdown because it was
technically very difficult to shoot but
we did it and it was awesome alright
where's this other thing here anybody
know where the other thing is I have to
jump down what's the deal here
I found this one oh I didn't find it I'm
dumb idiot I love Li every time I get
lost in the game is just always my fault
because I'm stupid
beat saber annoys me ah
like I said man I mean there's game you
look there's games for everybody that's
what's great about video games I'm not a
huge fan although I did love guitar hero
and rock band which is really fun it's
on the wall but it's white why were they
clueless what does that mean
cuz Conan's not a gamer so that's the
that's the joke it's on the wall but
it's white okay it's white you say
do you guys see anything Emma do you see
me any of this symbol anywhere where
where no I there's two of them I have
those two there's oh oh I'm dumb no
thanks
youth guys youth that's what it takes
here we go there it is there it is my
old aged eyes couldn't find it alright
did you get what was the deal with that
was the thing where people are hearing
two different things that basically old
people could hear one and young people
could hear the other it was like yeah
Yanni or Carl or something captain
Iggy two or three I don't know how to
say that I don't know what to say but uh
I wish I spoke Turkish I wish I actually
spoke any other languages use r2 to
preview a route oh I see
oh I wish I could do this in my real
life I feel like it'd save me a lot of
trouble I think we gotta go this way
right right
the only route I see oh there we go this
is the route we want oh yeah baby give
me some of that sweet Android parkour Oh
what don't jump on to the same thing you
dumb robot
Jonnie Jonnie or laurel there we go he
would have loved it would have loved
what I miss that yani or Laurel thank
you myth or alley a Li what's my
favorite game of all time ah man don't
make me say my favorite game of I don't
really know what it is um obviously have
games that are very close to my heart
might the game I'm recommending to
everybody right now
is this game inside which I really loved
it's basically don't read anything about
it it's a side scroller it's amazing
it's made by the guys who did limbo it's
super fun oh there we go
I can't that was great he'll blade
Center his sacrifice played on earphones
was amazing braid is one of my favorite
games of all time
[Music]
that's a bad noise I love games that
surprise me
games I've played a lot I mean Red Dead
Redemption one of my favorite games The
Last of Us obviously great Skyrim unreal
fallout 3 I loved those are all
fantastic Super Mario 2 I have friends
that Jordan Pablo Juarez Jordan I used
to go out to dinner a lot actually if
you'll believe it in New York and one
time we sat next to the Natalie Portman
and I had no idea for the entire thing
of dinner do and Jordan was acting kind
of weird throughout - and you know weird
for Jordan during dinner and then the
girl got applause he's like that was
Natalie Portman I was like oh I didn't
realize I was like bro like tell me
he'll blade was great I got to meet the
woman by the way the main character in
Hell blade and I kind of geeked out a
little bit what's going on here well see
it just made a game of e3 I mean for me
I loved cyberpunk was dope even just for
the fashion what am I doing here anybody
swing onto the pole oh wow oh I see go
up on the on the wall then swing up onto
the pole right got it got it thanks guys
thank you chat y'all are the best it's
my favorite hero Noah are we talking
like Avengers I love Batman because he's
a normal guy well I mean he's insane but
you know he's just he does having
superpowers he's all about like being a
detective and being smart and all that
stuff I love the Hulk was my favorite
when I was a kid and still is my
favorite because he just I'm sure it's
because I you know my father had rage
issues so I'm sure that's what the issue
was but no and I love the whole he just
gets you know he just gets stronger the
madder he gets it's awesome and Secret
Wars or Secret Wars - he holds an entire
mountain range above his head
so anybody tried vampire it's not I
think it's not bad writing his terrible
combat - but it's a neat concept yeah I
mean I I again I like anything that
shows me something new that's why I love
hell-blade because it was this woman in
Viking
so as a mental illness and you play it
and all these voices are talking you I
thought was fantastic super smart super
scary very intriguing inside was great
for a number of reasons that I can't
really say without spoiling but unreal
and showed me a lot of new stuff I'd
never seen before the Hulk's great
Madeleine says Batman's not Avengers I
know team journey that's why I asked for
DC it's Batman for Marvel it's the Hulk
I also like I think I mean if you guys
want to talk comic books I could talk
all day if you haven't read profit
profit is an amazing an absolutely
amazing series of graphic novels there's
five of them so reimagining of a 90s
drab life filled superhero and redone
it's it's really really great and crazy
and good planetary Warren Ellis is
probably my favorite comic of all time
the global frequency is also amazing by
Warren Ellis my current favorite is
Jonathan Hickman east of West so good so
so insane and good but I love that stuff
what's happening here so I need to
there's a point at which I can look
around right when I reach a certain
point that's maybe that point is past
another way up
you guys love lies too this game is so
easy and simplistic and yeah I'm stuck
on like the easiest part it's literally
just looking around and I can't do it
okay
how very Doomsday Clock I'm not rising 7
I have to go to shine how old am I
Arthur Dahle oh uh well young at heart
but age wise I'm 62
I got gray hair and I was 14 I've
mooster eyes a lot so left left left
left
thank you YouTube chat coming through in
the clutch Oh YouTube chat sorry I ever
spoke bad about you baby i love you I
love you we're back we're back you and
me let's have dinner Friday alright
let's hear we go to unstable dead I knew
it
[ __ ] you Oh give me that parkour you
guys think the only reason why people do
parkour is cuz it's called parkour what
it was called like flavell flobble
nobody would do it go what are you doing
today man um nothing I'm gonna do some
flavell flobble half the half of it is
cool everybody just wants to be cool you
know oh here we go
also most things in French just sound
cool The Joker endgame what's that
started Debbie come execute this ability
would be cool in real life I agree I
replay Mass Effect
oh man the tower here's the deal I feel
like I got to start with Mass Effect one
or at least Mass Effect 2 right because
Mass Effect 3 is supposed to be so
incredible
Mass Effect Andromeda hurts sucked my
favorite video game reviewer donkey if
you don't know donkey by the way oh my
god video game donkey he's the only
video game reviewer I watch he's so so
funny
my dream is to have him on this stream
at some point which hopefully will do
but his thing about Mass Effect
Andromeda was one of the funniest
reviews I've ever seen yeah started
Divya here all the mass effects are
great play Minecraft we love Jay I won't
play it on this stream but I shall play
it
I seen you through yet donkeys amazing
flew in the Alpha yeah donkeys
incredible am i drinking in the
afternoon
Ethan Hale know what I do is I drink in
the morning and I drink a lot before I
come to work and then my buzz wears off
over the as the day goes on and I kind
of like a time it right it wears off
right as the show starts taping it 4:30
where is it on here I don't you can see
it let's see how long it will take me
figure out this one love this game can't
wait to see the choices you'll make
fantasy I gotta say I killed the dude
and it written it's haunted me I
terrible dreams that night by the way
terrible dreams oh I got you I got you
look at this come on man what are we
even doing
I played the witness I know what's up I
feel like once you've played the witness
which is the hardest puzzle game I've
ever played every all other videogame
puzzles are basically cake because that
game was just so amazing it at making
you think outside the box
child's play guys child's play what I do
on Conan to eath Bradbury nothing I
actually don't get paid to work here I
work at Taco Bell I love it it's my
favorite food and I just come in here I
volunteer this is more like community
service for what I've done
well it might life I got sentenced to 20
years community service at Gonen 20 more
claps I get from Schenn rise you Wow 24
that a man or a woman are no all right
what are we doing here beam and a
tombstone looking thing
see a beam over here I see a tombstone
looking thing angry Joe what's that
Danish day no I haven't played that a
vampire or is it vampyre haven't played
it and what's the deal it's like you're
a modern day vampire but you're good
until you don't want to suck the blood
of people or something and but you have
to what's the deal with it
I tried naked chicken taco I have not I
don't even know what that is is that
where they made it taco out of a fried
piece of chicken or something what's
happening here I'm a six year old I
actually did used to work at Kmart that
was an interesting job I have a lot of
great stories about Kmart which will not
be told in the stream uh Esteban what I
think death stranding is about I don't
know dude it looks awesome though I
can't wait for death straining kijima is
a genius uh yeah they say Elias Laird uh
I'm a doctor oh he's a Spokane Rhino
your doctor gets turned to a vampire and
you have to balance the two spectrums of
saving lives and taking them I love that
it's good idea have I ever been doing
III yes I have I've been do a couple
threes sup real Slim Shady I'll tell him
you said hi am I gonna play any other
Scrolls Alex Hall wants to ask ah I
don't know is if it's is it online
I'm not a big online play with other
people thing ah made you food we are
going to Comic Con I'll be there I'll
see you there
Jericho why is every like cool meetup
spot always called like Jericho or like
Eden or something what's it called and
Logan did you guys see you Logan
anybody see Logan what what was it what
was the place they're supposed to go it
couldn't just be called like Perth you
know or like Martha let's go meet up at
Martha not that Martha's not a great
name but you know what I'm saying
it's always like like how the facts oh
no I'm an Android I can't die DC meets
Looney Tunes whoo baby
Eden yeah yeah it's evening star gate
right fat burger right yeah it's never
like L Chamber it's never like we must
the chosen ones we will all meet up at
fat burger what are we doing by the way
if I ever become the leader of like
rebels or like you know like the chosen
one or something I'm definitely naming
the meetup spot like fat burger or like
blurb blurb guys we're gonna be our
salvation lies in blurb all right find
another way to the boat well could we
just go back the way we came
I mean can I just jump down don't I have
like metal legs dude come on what's the
point of being in you know I gotta say
Blade Runner 2049 did it right there's a
great moment in that where Harrison Ford
is running and Gosling is running and
Harrison Ford locks the door he Gosling
just runs through the wall of course he
would without hesitation he's an Android
he's super strong but not this guy the
stinkhole ha ha ha ha that's our exactly
rebels our salvation lies at this
stinkhole I'd be perfect I would love to
just find stairs somewhere isn't this
like a thing here
oh my god too much looking around
meet me at blurb for some flavell
flobble exactly and then we will take
over the human race when will I take my
bong rip Adam Malachi don't take them on
the air I have other people do them for
me and then they just tell me what to
say and little I have a little earpiece
that way I don't have to get high but I
can say things that are insane Jericho
the Bible has callously destroyed and
everyone inside got killed not the best
name your last resort to survive that's
true also is that there was a TV show
called Jericho right not great super
jump janitor's closet stream KOCO
astronaut istic when will I do a live
stream of Kona tutorials well not today
but very soon ken will be on the live
stream and we're gonna be doing some fun
stuff from comic-con so stay tuned for
that I think you guys will be very
excited it's being exciting if you're
just joining us stream we got our first
very first mobile clueless gamer coming
at you on Thursday with the hilarious
Ron Funches and a really fun oh now we
use our metal legs okay
Jericho is a great show that never got
finished on the thing you got cancelled
I think there should be a policy when
you cancel a show you should give them
one more episode like last man on earth
got cancelled and it ended on a crazy
cliffhanger
you know everybody should get like one
final episode just ND why I mean you are
here I don't need to say it dude to a
Just Cause 3 with Conan maybe yeah
Funches is amazing my Gus he's really
really funny he's a great guy and he's a
gamer can't go this way I do love games
that are pitch black make this a little
bit brighter here what are we doing
crank it there we go yeah resume
oh great see the outline it oh sorry
how far along the story captain wreck
I'm not quite sure I'm pretty far though
I mean there's some shits gone down dude
pretty intense I mean I've already
clawed clawed my way out of a graveyard
yeah that's hooey 78 everybody's tagging
the wrong Jordan that's probably true no
luckily somebody left this all right oh
this is Midway damn this game's long
it's Conan open to making more content
for this YouTube famous Yoshi my man we
make content for YouTube every day I put
so many clips of our show on this
YouTube channel Midway do I fear air AI
ooh
ah that's a good question you know I got
a sick I got one of those Google home
things you know and it's an ik and it
it's connected to some smart lightbulbs
in my house I got his gift it's
interesting it's weird to talk to it and
have it do things that is a weird thing
and I know like the government's
listening in on all my conversations
which are boring
ah why is this scary again isn't this
where the people are supposed to be that
are gonna help me let's see where did
they come from
oh so it was impossible for them to come
from over here cool uh it's a little
weird I got to say having the a I talk
back to you a little weird but I welcome
in man I mean you know bring it on I
mean humans are doing a great job of
taking care of this planet as it is so
let's let the robots take care of him
it'll be smarter by the way I have a
theory that our K 800 is called Conner
because it's homophonic with coroner oh
that's interesting
maybe or maybe he's a con man hey
captain boy of Oda let's see what this
game is all about if you played it at
all
thank you for joining us I'm on your
celebrity crush list it's all about me
well I shouldn't because I smell weird
and I'm kind of too tall but I list to
the side so if I close my eyes and walk
straight I just end up walking around in
this circle so there's a lot that's
wrong with me guys
not I'm not a crush I'm not crush-worthy
Jarvis Peter mother the focus on making
more online content I'm not sure what
you guys are talking about but I like it
cuz I'm into making online content you
know look alright let me say something I
know this is all dramatic and great
first rule of wanting people to join
your cause have somebody at Jericho to
welcome you you know set up a table with
some cookies or whatever androids eat
how about a little welcoming party here
this is like why would anybody join this
this is so ridiculous this doesn't make
me wanted this doesn't look like a well
thought out rebellion alright and or a
proper uprising oh here we go let's put
two soon why didn't you just show up
when I first came into the boat do you
all have to like stand around me like a
bunch of dukes
alright also I will say this is one of
my favorite parts about this game and
great job to the Detroit become human
people this is the tree when you
complete every level you get to see all
the choices you could have made and so
it makes you want to replay stuff
because this is not a good example but
there are four interest for example
there are mome levels where it's just
like it looks insane and goes crazy
and that's really fun I think that's
really exciting it's kind of like I love
it super meatboy how it shows you every
single when you complete the level it
shows you every single death at the same
time so you can kind of see your
progression and the ones you made
all right at please see if thieves it's
great does he die I'm not good at it but
it's fun and I love that idea
see man even Androids got problems I
gotta be cool with my human guy the wink
chapter I'm not that is we're gonna see
the wink
what's the week
Andrew Navarro I'd like to see Khoda
play the new super smash - we did a
clueless gamer with it before it was
really good captain wreck I missed your
question sorry jeez just talk to Hank
you'll see the wink says so glad
I didn't by the way who says unpleasant
kurgan yeah exactly man the kurgan I
just wanted to take out a sword get
crazy you know I gotta say something if
you're trying to be nice to the human
guy don't scan his food how invasive is
this this is exactly the kind of stuff I
think he hates breach of hygiene Oh No
yeah boy ain't been washing his hands
after two and we got a problem here man
oh it's gonna have lice or something all
right don't tell them what the right
thanks the voice of mr. Krabs you scan
everything I'm scanning everything dude
oh that's cool I just go in the kitchen
start scanning stuff I'm scanning it all
I gotta see this week basically Android
is Jordan makes the best burger in
Detroit
gambling let's leave
yeah discretion is the better part of
valor Connor this is like me on a date
uh can I tell anything about myself I'm
very narcissistic oh my god shut up dude
shut your mouth shut up stop talking
stop talking stop talking stop talking
all right DV he would hate this mousse
the Frog Canadian he would hate this he
will be living much longer if he gets
food from hygiene man every day
fallout 76 is canceled there's something
I can unlock and Henry killed my wife
don't make it like an Android killed his
wife please
yeah we have you seen Westworld there's
a cool question when AI becomes as good
as this would you rather have robots you
could buy for personal use like this
game or if the robots an amusement park
controlled by one person like a
westerner ooh good question I forgot I'm
gonna say true what I rather have run
around I think
let's if they're as self-aware as the
ones in West world or these I don't
think it's fair to keep them in a theme
park I don't think that's fair I think
they should be out in the world sincere
and rude were life like it'd be enough
it be edible
Touche I just I mean I guess we found
out who the cannibal was what about you
guys would you rather have Androids walk
the streets or in an amusement park I
wasn't paying attention but I feel like
from that music and what just happened I
kind of might have screwed up and it's
like this is a shot of him not liking me
what was the week I missed the wink
come on Oh where's the wig I'm coming
gross
I missed the wink
I'm gonna have to go back and watch the
stream oh my god Aaron I take my Coney
20 claps baggers I'm back to zero claps
god damn it he did do it Steven to Perry
drinking a beer now I'm a tequila guy
but right now I've had six cold brew
coffee and I'm yelling which everybody
hates including streets because then
they wouldn't really differ from us if
they had consciousness they would just
look different not have to consume the
food that we need that's true Moses
if Android's becomes self-aware we have
to give them equal rights can't just
keep a high light elegent life for me to
do I agree that's true man it's like if
they're self-aware it feels kind of mean
right
it wouldn't be candle ism because they
aren't human it's cannibalism really
that bad I mean come on let's be honest
why don't I just go first because I
could just be replaced right Jesus where
ya from whoa Oh baby lots of stuff to
scam scan sorry Thanks
you know what to be great as an Android
you don't have to smell stuff you can
just turn every turn your stuff up Oh
contraire Clancy Brown I think we came
for something Hank's the best
yeah I agree X oh my god Isaiah Han Hort
unknown yes I agree with you
anything else on here radiator thing and
he kind of radiator leak carbon monoxide
poisoning anything la la is he though
the old Shawshank oh sorry
it's a lot of what is this weirdest porn
I've ever seen they're manufactured
products I'm against giving them too
much intellectual freedom whoo I love it
what is up with all these birds man
we've been feeding these birds is there
even any food in here for these birds
what's going on out of the way bird huh
oh I see am i hunting down an Android
Mike Tyson cuz I like this dude might be
kind of magus Detroit beyond birds there
are so many birds at this apartment
oh this is the oh they took their is
this work Oh gross
I'll never get over that wait is this
Cara is this where I took my uh no this
isn't where I took my head piece out
right um read my nature what are you
talking about I did love Resident Evil 7
that was awesome am I gonna play fallout
76 if I do could I wear the fallout
seats for the last fallout comment this
if you agree you know one thing I one
thing I don't know if I've told a lot of
people is when we shot that cold-open
for the Fallout game or fallout 4 gamer
is Conan had to leave he had to leave
early and we had to do some kind of way
to do some reshoots of coming down the
ladder into the vault where we ended up
playing which was actually our insert
stage and they made us these skin-tight
vault suits vinyl vault leads which
didn't breathe very well they were very
very hot and so my vault suit was
different from Conan's so Conan had to
leave so I had to put on his vault suit
and play his body double to come down
the ladder and it was full of sweat it
was disgusting
and I actually the photo I'll show you
of that because we almost have to go so
we'll end on this alright great wooden
stool alright so we're gonna end on this
so could you go fullscreen for me so
this is when I had to put on
Conan's vault suit this is exactly
somebody took a photo of it right after
I put it on so first of all there's this
is a photo of us and our vault seats if
you haven't seen it they're amazing by
the way the vault seats were incredible
you're gonna focus for me skin tight
skin tight alright and I and when I had
to pull his thing I put it on and
someone immediately took of like stepped
up and snapped a photo so this is my
real reaction to it let's see if I can
find it now
let's see this is right after I put on
Conan's vault suit I'm you can see it
there it's awful this is what it you
never want to be covered in Conan
O'Brien's sweat this is exactly what it
feels you can see look if you you look
close you can see my soul leaving my
body right here see so leave my body
guys thank you all for joining us for
stream Coco we're back baby I'm gonna
love seeing what's coming out of a 3
thank you all for watching make sure you
tune in to Conan Thursday night that's
tomorrow night for our very first mobile
clueless game worth Ron Funches
presented by a google play of course
it'll be online as well to watch that
and thank you all for joining us we will
see you guys next time see you later